je dirais il y a d'énormes avantages on
commence avec le pouvoir d'achat qui est
énorme avec avec l'autre Canada il y a à
peine 10 jours le président de l'os
Canada vantait encore les bienfaits pour
Rona d'appartenir à son réseau mais
voilà que l'OSE se départit de ses
bannières canadiennes
c'est une vente de feu c'est clair que
on nettoie les livres en 2016 l'OSE
achetait pour 3,2 milliards de dollars
plus de 500 magasins des bannières Rona
Réno-Dépôt et d'exclumber en 2022 la
société en capital de risque Sicka
morpartners peut aussi peu que 540
millions de dollars pour 450 magasins
longtemps prévoit toutefois une
contrepartie différée fondée sur le
rendement si on est actionnaire chez
l'OZ USA échec et c'est un échec
d'autant plus je pense que lorsqu'on
regarde la façon que ça a été annoncé en
fin de journée communiquer de pas
nécessairement eu de rumeurs avec la
vente les magasins canadiens lauze
deviendront des Rona et la chaîne
d'approvisionnement restera intacte
selon Richard Darvault tous les contrats
d'approvisionnement étaient signés avec
Rona ink et le demeure donc pour les
gens qui nous écoutent j'ai l'impression
qu'ils vont retrouver leur gamme de
produits auxquels ils sont habitués et
que le nom Rona va devenir peut-être
plus populaire que jamais c'est d'abord
avant tout une décision bêtement
financière c'est à dire que
la difficulté à aller chercher le même
la même rentabilité avec ces opérations
au Canada que ce qu'elle réussit à faire
aux États-Unis le concept des
entreprises affiliées si cher à Rona
freine la rentabilité vous n'êtes pas un
grossiste détaillant vous ne faites
office que de grossistes et c'est
beaucoup plus difficile évidemment gérer
une pluriel de petits détails ce
changement de mai n'a pas d'impact sur
les consommateurs
des transactions qui nous dépassent je
pense pas que mon achat aujourd'hui
offert une grosse différence mais
certains auraient aimé que Rona revienne
dans le giron québécois les gens
d'affaires d'ici auraient pu prendre et
cette offre avec la perte de valeur de
l'entreprise des investisseurs canadiens
auraient la capacité financière de
racheter la bannière reste à voir s'ils
auront la volonté et quand si Camors
vendra ses actifs ici Marie-Josée
Paquette como Radio-Canada Montréal